the people of the book
you may have heard this expression
before regarding the Jewish people it's
because many Jewish people have a deep
love and reverence for the Hebrew
scriptures the book of Torah but
actually it's somewhat of a misnomer
when it comes to the Jewish people
because the Jewish faith for millennium
for Generations was passed down from one
generation to the other verbally it's an
oral tradition in fact
the Jewish faith is one of many many
oral Traditions that impact our culture
and many other cultures tonight we're
going to look at one type of oral
tradition oral history
so first of all what is oral history
well it's a way to get at historical
events through the lens of individual
experiences through interviews it's a
way to capture what happened with
people's memories and perceptions of
what transgressed in the past
but why do we care well often the
official historical narrative leaves out
critical voices and perspectives many
times marginalized disenfranches
disenfranchised voices are left out at
the narrative and so it gives us an
incomplete picture of History
10 years ago no actually 13 years ago
almost to the day Frank Gavin an
historian came to the long now and
shared his vision his perspective of
History which is that horizontal history
many factors come into play to affect
the historical narrative well I would
posit that oral history is the human
lens it's the overlay among all these
variables to give meaning and
explanation to what happens in the
history it's sort of like an accounting
statement with footnotes they make it
make sense
Steven Spielberg totally understood the
power of oral history when he was making
Schindler's List he realized that there
were so many human stories that needed
to be told not only to complete the
picture of the Holocaust but to help us
connect with it as humans and he knew
that was important so he partnered with
USC to start the showa foundation they
collect thousands of Holocaust Survivor
stories so that not only do we know more
about the Holocaust but we understand on
a human level what it meant and we
learned from it
Isabelle Wilkerson uses oral history
significantly in her study of the Great
Migration She interviewed over 1200
people and did a deep dive interviewing
intensely three of these people between
1915 and 1970 70 over 6 million African
Americans left the South to other parts
of the U.S to get better Economic
Opportunity but especially to escape the
racial regime of Jim Crow
so some of the folks that she focused on
included Ida May Brandon gladney
she was living in Mississippi with her
husband when her husband's cousin was
nearly killed for stealing some turkeys
so pregnant with two small children her
and her husband left for Chicago to find
opportunity instead they found a gladded
labor market and they were competing not
only with other migrants but with
immigrants they became the bottom of the
pecking order again
it was not pretty
George Foster Starling is another person
that Isabelle Wilkerson spoke with he
was born in Florida and college educated
and soon learned and understood that
they were being exploited in the fields
and so he organized his co-laborers to
demand more money he was nearly killed
so he went to New York City
there he didn't see white signs or
colored signs and he could go to a bar
and get served but the bartender would
make it very clear that he wasn't
welcome by Smashing the glass loudly
upon his departure
and finally Dr Robert Joseph Pershing
Foster was an accomplished physician and
surgeon in World War II but when he
returned to Monroe Louisiana he learned
that he couldn't even do a simple
tonsillectomy so he went to Los Angeles
so he could practice medicine but sadly
even the journey there began to reveal
the kind of obstruction and resistance
he would face
driving up to a hotel and a vacancy sign
becomes a No Vacancy sign the subtle
rejection and exclusion continued all
these stories tell us that the Great
Migration while leading to Economic
Opportunity also didn't close
the limitations and the oppression that
many black people faced and because
these are human stories we can relate to
them on a personal level and reflect
so I would ask you who in your backyard
has lived through an historical event
small or large
what are their perceptions their
memories
what did they experience and what can
they add to the historical narrative
get curious and do some research and
then turn on your phone and ask them
some questions and capture it and if
they agree share it with others so that
others not only have a fuller picture of
history but they connect with it as
humans
thank you